we are Lara
welcome back to the campfire and the
last word with Lord Camino and he butts
his fresh on a Friday morning how are
you doing sir there's a lot going on
with destiny man speak we threw out last
week were in the doldrums right now
we're in this half time zone dude even
on Tuesday I log in and I was like hey
there's probably not that much going on
I thought about doing a weekly reset I
was like I don't know it's like I can
work out like in an hour and then come
back and start my stuff literally drive
to the studio you're like getting ready
for class like checking Twitter I was
like oh god what is going on what is
this I mean I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I
got the workout in because normally it
was like at the time but there wasn't
exactly a rush but we'll kind of get
into that but yeah better like how how
much have you been into this thing
because I've been deeper in then I
thought I was oh oh
you froze my boys frozen no he's got a
frozen screen oh he's back he's back
joven yeah go right here first weird all
right
oh he's back he's nice that was a very
weird
he was fusing the corner of time just
did anyway oh so it looks like we're
back on chat let us know if we back
official there's a home yeah so for me I
would be honest like I didn't know what
the hell was going on so I was just
sitting there I was like what is this
and oh you know yo Cyrus has a quest and
you know we're trying to figure out
what's going on and um then yeah we
start the quest and I'm like alright let
me jump in there and I just was in this
maze and I'm like yeah I don't know what
this is I'm not smart enough to even
decipher what this is so I'm gonna fall
back and let the experts do this and I'm
gonna reap the benefits when y'all
figure it out and I'm figuring it's
probably like an hour - how is it
something you know rate sequencing nah
yeah this is something different
this is something completely different
I'm amazed at how far is going on but I
want it I want to start not attack you
but I want to just give some lashings
out to community because just recently a
bunch of people and I want to shout out
some people to you know went on stream
and they were talking about you know
these quests are too easy
honey you know there's nothing to do it
is I don't know and I missed complex
destiny and hard destiny and the hard
core needs to be whoa damn it you got
something to do so go figure that with
your hardcore got nothing to do laughs
and destiny self I mean that's that's
been literally a funny thing you've seen
out there everybody's like oh it's too
easy but it's like oh well here you go
no it's too hard yeah yeah yeah smack
them right into my love with buns you
did smack them right you know what's
funny Bungie knows us they don't they
knew after that Devils ruling which part
of the Commission who made this was like
devil sir and be like oh this is too
easy they're like just and it's
literally like the evil exit like just
used
just you wait week in history cometh
exactly here's the funny part remember
me and you even alluded we were like
look we looked at that map we were like
oh yeah there's a big whole week it's
too much of a gap me you both here do we
like nah man something's cooking in here
we don't know what you know but
something's cooking in and see where it
goes down like Anna shot the WB Prescott
filly is not your type of game play we
got to see where it leads now I want to
kind of talk about something but it's
kind of spoilery and I don't know if you
want to go there but I kind of want to
go to it I think you know what I've
talked about did you read the okay
did you read Tassie's latest article no
maybe about okay did you leave always
for you spoils I'm gonna be very vague
to the chat and anybody who does not
want me to spoil and Twitter he's an old
troll and everybody which is my yeah
people are trolling however they have
been data mined of certain things and I
just want to know if y'all know not
saying that this is where this whole
thing leads but one particular thing was
found with audio tracks of a certain
person we know
and and it's it's a very interesting
concept so I don't know if you know what
I'm talking about I don't think you all
did you know oh damn I can't talk about
it it is I will say this this wood has
been data mined
Forte knows what I'm talking yeah Forte
definitely knows we was in Nam we was on
a Twitter stream together what has been
data mined if true shots at highway come
back if true
is a very unique concept
and I was all I will say is that if true
I can see how this concept can set up
destiny three based on just one thing
and it's it's a lot but yeah all I will
say is for something that's been found
based on what's been found and data
mined there has been audio data mined
and the audio is very very important and
portal and chilling so yeah it's it's
deep bro it's deep so we're gonna touch
it I know sound tomato salad over this
yeah migas pieces sadly I know about
that I love I think it is probably one
of bungees coolest ideas I think it's
definitely gonna happen we might get to
that the end because I want to kind of
read it with you site a baby scanned it
but I was like yeah we might save the
over spoiler so save it for the NSA for
the spoiler thank you yeah yeah we will
we will mention that towards the end
complete giant warning caveat flailing
arms and all that stops though whoo that
will be I am a surgery he not he's a
year I read all of it what you did well
you should have I will say it's one of
these kind of moments they go and do
this whoa I don't know I was like I
didn't read that deep and you know but
it's like something this expansive mmm
like this level of puzzle and they never
better get something to be in they've
said they couldn't be sending us on a
wild goose chase for how the puzzles
being sold but either way it's like it
can't be small this cannot be something
small and honestly we did it again for
just an exotic like outbreak it was like
even that wasn't gonna be good enough
for me but that was gonna be good enough
this outbreak was over nineteen hours
figuring out our codes walking through
putting the puzzle together and then
getting the emblem and then being like
oh damn there's a Phase two
that's like outbreak was phase
of this thing I feel yes yes this is
like man oh shout out dizzy when the
stop is say go it's a little disapprove
sheight your breath water oh yeah man
this is definitely next level man it's
um it's it's definitely intense um III I
cannot wait when we get to it because my
mind cannot stop thinking about it
that's where we are right now cuz I'm
dying to talk about we'll get to but
every other than that you know it was
cool to see that this is a very um
community driven kind of thing let's
just be real this is for a hawk or this
is for Yui this is for you guys to get
together put your little Maps and your
hexagrams do you little biochemistry
diagrams you know you guys that sabi is
it the most action-packed they know but
it's gonna lead to something is they
leave some big I was like so for those
who don't know what in the hell we are
talking about
unless for some reason you know been
living under a rock for a little while
or something of that nature mm-hmm
want me to break it down kind of like
the progression of what happened this
week okay everything's like mind-blowing
people like what actually happened so
mmm-hmm basically we log in on Tuesday
there's a Questor Osiris it says hey you
expound sate 14 maybe there's more in
the corridors of time like okay so as
you said go into the corridors of time
same probably like I did I was like okay
I went right in and I was like this just
seems to be going there's no end and I
was even in Twitter like chat for a
little while I was like you guys have
any idea what the hell's going on here
like cuz I tried to put no spoilers in
chat and I was like hey maybe you'll
figure something out in here and then
somebody's I think in Twitter and like
quick scrolling somebody was like
obelisk I was like I'm sorry what then
you go to the obelisk and you're like oh
there's a code
what's the code well then I took that
code back into I was like okay so these
are the same symbols went back into the
corridors then we're trying to figure
out how to read this thing I was like
okay so start at the top go around I
didn't work let me start it at one that
actually did work when you go in the
middle then we get to the end we get our
first little symbol in the floor so I
take a picture of that because this
thing has a bit more crap all over it
and you get a lower page and then we can
get the Lord page people like yeah it's
one of 19 and you're like God and I said
when do you get the next one they're
like yeah they're coming every hour I
was like I'm sorry what 19 hours we
gotta wait for this thing it was like I
have to wake up at like 4:30 in the
morning I'm not gonna make it but as
long as I could like sticking with them
waiting every hour kind of messing
around in there and that's why I was
doing what I was doing I was like
alright well we have to wait every hour
we can't force this thing for most of it
because he can't really like even brute
force it until you know a lot of it
mm-hm
just like guess the path yeah there's a
lot of them so I was trying something
completely different to where I was like
okay
so if you kill in the same same door
every time what happens because it's
like going in well yes and no right
first times it's a loop thanks to Mia's
who was helping me last night as well he
went through the hex door a hundred
times Pam
that man was definitely putting in some
work - Pam did loop but this is after
wheat so first time I went through I was
like okay so I made it through like 13
anything being 14 so I had to go back
through but they're not totally random
like if you start on one and you head
down a certain path you're gonna see the
same things every time right like
whatever that sequence is isn't totally
random for at least a long long time so
I was like okay does this mean something
can you actually start like mapping out
the connections to how this place is put
together mmm
that kind of fell off as like the 19
puzzle came out and I slept I was
everybody didn't woke up and then people
had all 19 of absolved they had to
figure out the exact path of the 19 you
get to be in and you get a new symbol so
you know you're not done you are done so
you get an emblem so that's like a tiny
checkbox and they like Mayhem's your
life hmm so now the symbol now the one
at the end that threw me is the fact
that there so every one of the little
basically you get to the end for anybody
who hasn't done this yet I'm just trying
to explain it Ferb I do listen Russ as
well you would go through every time you
would in a room there was five doors
above each door was a symbol and
basically the code would be the kind of
you're gonna go in door number one first
and then two and then one and then five
and that's kind of had you'd go through
when you get to the end it says time
lost of all mm-hmm and what it would be
is in the middle of the room is this
little kind of grassy platform sitting
on like a glass stage basically small
little plaque that looks like it has the
character classes and then one other
filler symbol it looks like a small tomb
with a sword on the top which everybody
keeps one more link exotic swords are
coming back that's one of the big
theories that was pretty quick the sword
you could probably have a decent theory
on that mm and then below the floor
and also above's I guess the underneath
but like a mirror is all these little
gray hexagons and one big hexagon in the
middle mmm-hmm as soon as it has this
little like when you get to the edge of
the glass it's like questions--
questions-- questions-- you can activate
it like a button you do that you look
down and then all these symbols start
showing up so the same ones you were
running through the doors are on the
ground and then of the big hexagon which
is surrounded by a whole bunch of little
little ones is like lines to draw the
hexagon they could be solid or there
could be a gap mmm that night took all
19 of those getting put together to
build the original map because the gap
means yeah you can move through here
like a maze it's an open space mm-hmm
but every one of those had a symbol in
the middle every single one had a clover
a hex diamond whatever it was there was
something in the middle when you go to
the end of the xix typically if you look
at the odds yours isn't gonna have a
squat in the middle it's gonna have the
jigsaw like orientation set up on the
outside like all the little symbols on
the outside if you picture a jigsaw
puzzle with the like you know weird
little wiggle piece that's gonna connect
to the opening of the wiggle piece spot
basically what it works is if like those
seven symbols match to those seven
symbols on the other side they go
together God should all that may be said
there's no soul he said there's a go
shell at the end of the sword and the
symbol on the plaque is the one that
represents the vanguard is what he's
saying know all the lines okay
cool cool cool chapter buh bugles
tasties but coming up with uh two perks
for a weapons that he submitted to bunch
the divorcer some stuff in life right
now yeah you definitely was it was Dada
enthused while watching this quest so he
came up with perks to give the Bungie
salut
that's too funny of course their alimony
palimony have every convention
enemies health care but those are brutal
those are brutal the divorce Alec come
on like Twitter they've had a
progression of so but the difference is
when I get to the end and I see my
jigsaw piece we're and I look down it's
got it's got no symbol in the middle
it's got a hexagon with like maybe two
sides open it's got all the pieces
around mmm the one I get the end at the
end is different than what you and
everybody else gets at the end hmm
so then now people are like okay
everybody's getting stiffer and stuff
this is where the community started
coming together big streamers of course
have large audiences Sony started
pulling people in they were putting
databases together saying they basically
made like letter codes for like the
jigsaw puzzles what's the middle symbol
which sides are open mm-hmm and fell
asleep watching me to my spreadsheet
yeah yes yeah this is not the stream
time for everybody I will tell you there
it is clearly has been a lot of fun for
some of us mm-hmm but yeah so they're on
like I was watching the spreadsheet
yesterday Ilona was part of it too and
he was on like line 3000 or something
insane she's yeah like every but cuz
it's like you can do one per character
and I don't know if it's per hour you
can get a new one but then just keep
submitting these things to the like wow
the collective mind basically I'm trying
to put it together and then Photoshop
people are like going through trying to
build this thing and the image is so
ridiculously big it's not even funny
this is gonna where we're at so phase 1
you go through that you figure out the
19 pieces you could technically do that
yourself once you figure out all 19
codes then you can go through put the
map together figure out how to get
through it the opening to the exit go
through get your emblem and then when
you get your piece mm-hmm yeah Pike we
have we're not doing yeah we don't know
but data miners definitely have been
talking but we will cover spoilers at
the end mm-hmm so yeah we have giant
puzzles in like there they've taken
they've made you know a 50 piece
connection it doesn't seem to make sense
there's a lot of space pieces there's a
lot of like lines and walls that don't
connect there isn't a path of anything
yet but they have huge connections and
things going in there so I don't know
man after is like seeing
do you want to late take the person yet
bungee and shake their hand or slap them
I'm kind of curious
Lizabeth a bead again these type of
things
notorious notoriously for me I have
never done like even during an outbreak
crime and they did had to binary and
like dude I would say when you I'll
figure it out I'll let you boy
I will job will join name video over
type up a guide will put on the words of
gaming dotnet no won't be there you go
his legs and that's where it's gonna go
up here when you guys finish it so my
thing is don't get me wrong dude the way
I look at like this Devils ruin what's
for me I got my lure I got my banter
that I've always wanted with Saint and
Osiris and Shaq's I'm good so this right
here I guess I said this is for the
hardcore of the hardcore and I love that
it exists I love that it exists it's
just not anything I pride myself on
doing like that's literally where I'm at
with this I am very curious though to
see where it goes you know I'm saying
I'm also I have to ask you a couple
questions since you've been very needy
penis um is any of this part of my
savior triumph that I need to get no
hey oh okay I thought I had to do this
now there's a let you if you go through
and put all 19 like go through the
corridors of time 19 times there's a 19
page lore book that you can get but none
of this is specifically I haven't seen
at least I don't think it's part of the
triumphs or secret times in there you're
like cuz I was yeah I was worried that
maybe the 19 or some part of that that
emblem maybe that's a source question
it's like mm-hmm
there's a lot of there's a couple of
secret ones inside the dam now I did
legend sundial and again shout out to
Ella destiny PC LMG y'all salut my first
time doing it uh a noob to it so easy
sobbing seconds brother sex someone put
it out Hey
running sundown got four join is a join
slash with you know cold you literally
copy page that into your text box and
boom shoot you right into the fire team
and we're ready to go do legend I'm like
alright it was seamless and they were
all text chat and hanging everybody
before we're in orbit everybody's got
with a guy are you ready
you know I guess we had a good group
knock that bad boy out and you know some
very I just wanna I guess I that's new
you done that was that the one you used
for what's arm I used to discord I used
a disk our destiny yeah used and Pro to
discord from Bungie definitely to PC LMG
fire nice that is the way I'm super now
mind you I'm coming from Xbox and I'm an
Xbox lfg guy no I know I will ride or a
die with that like that's one of the
best experience cuz place doesn't have
it
I have to admit I do the fact you got
talked it away because everybody's just
texting away like it's like now I got a
C though in defense Xbox I got to see
how that works with a rape because
what's cool is they have all the UM the
raids arm which co-listed so it'll be
like scourge you know arms what's called
the past Leviathan
yeah different activities and I was the
population in there is I mean literally
out you know I tested it cuz you know
how I still need to do Spira start stars
cuz I really want my sleeper catalyst
right I was looking in Leviathan and the
spire stars lfg text chat room bro it
was like every ten five ten minutes
hey ready to run hey my guys running
sharper ring in there too nice
I'm like wow impressive so that's that
so I just got to find out what I need
left or my um lore book because I Savior
is gonna be the first title I go for I
just want to make sure I don't miss it
but yeah I just want to know in
reference to the quest is there anything
do we know if anything is tied I don't
think yeah okay I don't - me what you're
gonna need the whole lore book for it
they haven't done that with a title I
guess they have with other ones like
curse break do you need like the full
lore bits but I don't think it is
maybe like I don't know I haven't looked
I haven't checked that triumph in a
little while off to check it after this
one could be wrong if it is my chat
listeners all that don't don't throw me
under the bus yet but yeah it is aw
Prescott she was saying that he had
given credit everyone working on it but
it's not likely they can list out every
name a person adding a screenshot plus
two this is the time think of personal
attribution this is a time when you work
as a whole doing our part and it gets
solved because we all pitched in I think
that's the general consensus this is a
community event and that's why I like I
say it's not my cup of tea but I like
the concept beyond I like what it's
doing for you guys I like that you guys
are coming together I like seeing the
hardcore happy about doing something
that excites me I like we got also
killing you and Dylan or eight damage
just like we also won't put out the
twelve until glad gets him he's got
blood in his caffeine stream at this
point but mm-hm yeah some of those
people need to sleep yes
and they have been treatin shifts and
stuff back and forth a little bit but
shifts I'm serious like hey I'm taking
off let me go ahead and give it over to
sweat cycle he's gonna do it alone O's
always up in the morning he's a loving
lock morning shift
like I have seen different people for
the last few days make this rotation
it's the beauty of destiny this is what
- these at its best when we have those
secrets again they know what they gotta
do it that's why again I'm tryna dying
for season and Dawn it is the first
season there is no rain no dungeon no
premium pinnacle PvP activity and we are
still finding ways to have fun that's
impressive
regardless of what people say that's
impressive man
yeah so evening the menagerie but it's
number two opulence but number two
number two Annual Pass okay well yeah
that had a read and the menagerie that
is like it's pretty it's a pretty
stacked deck there it's pretty stacked
decorate hmm
yeah so we had
to me master Excel yeah but even like
last night for example nose work with me
Gus and some of the chat mm-hmm some of
you guys were definitely in there and
passed through but it's weird how the
the quarters of timer set up because if
you don't know the code you can just
honestly go like straight or pick it or
and just go forever
doesn't really seem to have an issue but
there are only four main rooms in there
there's a cauldron room there's a tree
room there's the one with the pillar in
the middle kind of a busted pillar and
then there's one like a baby traveler in
the middle right those are the only four
rooms now some have lasers some have
electric floors yeah but it did seem and
this is where I'm wondering how this
thing is built great like I some weird
crazy matrix thing because we were
testing this Magus and I were last night
mm-hmm
I had and it works out that I had the
ammo finder on cuz those things closed
so they're very obvious but I had like a
heavy mo brick a blue in Graham in a
heavy ammo brains like in a pretty
specific spot I was like all right I'm
just gonna keep running through the top
middle door and the next thing to come
back it was over here on my left
what they're doing over there same like
our side of the room but now it's on the
left then I'd go for a half of more
doors and it's over by the start on my
right-hand side I'm like what we doing
over here
what and then I'd run through again and
to be off to the left then I'd run
through this back in the original spot
is back in the original spot like four
times in a row then it jumped or AV
don't like in my head I can't figure out
and I was also wondering it's like is
this thing like a Rubik's Cube
or like if you go through a certain door
it's like okay so you change one piece
of this and you're like moving moving
one set of symbols or maybe you change
the order of the rooms where you maybe
change if there's lasers in there's like
I was trying to figure out if any
certain combinations of things would
like change you through because
depending on how its set up and you have
five rooms if you go five times four
times three times two times one you get
that math which is always a little crazy
cuz that's 120 then if you have four
rooms with and without lasers that's
eight so you got 960 different rooms mmm
and then if you go electric floor not
you can have a few more variations I
don't know how many there is there
you've got a lot of rooms and it says
explore and find the secrets and I'm
like right now I'm just trying to
explore every freaking room god bless
you aids yeah it's just been weird as
we're going through and I'm like why is
this in Graham and I am oh you guys the
stuff moving why that's what I'm like
I'm wondering how the instances does the
instance even matter cuz every time you
go through the bridge it's the flash and
that's your next room you know that's
like you're inputting the code but
mm-hmm each story is interesting I mean
like back is a one row yeah yeah I mean
citrus they definitely utilize in that
infinite forest algorithm but the fact
that it's moving pieces on the ground
stuff like that yeah that is very trippy
zero I mean that's even if somebody I
forget it was one of them in my chat
last night was saying think of infinite
forest but what we would go through for
like haunted forest you'd like go to an
end and you'd turn around and you'd when
we were a rivalry I think whatever
you're going through you'd like bounce
around and just kind of stay in the area
so if you got back to a platformer
there'd be like up floating ammo and
then it like fall to the ground and
you'd be like see the same areas but it
would
it wouldn't be just like you walk in and
poof it's just over here instead it was
Graham I'm still wondering cuz it's not
like hey it's over here and then finally
it falls off the map or something like
that no it's very specifically always
stuck in this room just in a different
orientation just a different order he
that is interest I'm dying to know if we
ever speak to a dead leg oh god you know
we'll pick somebody spring about this
yeah they'd pick the brain on like how
did the creation process of that and
then how that kind of stuff kind of
happens it does in from an engine wise
cuz it's a very cool concept very unique
well they used like the bridge because
any money it's all about loading screens
not having me so as you drive through
small areas they unload what was just
behind you and then they load what's
coming in front so same thing every room
is gonna get loaded as you go between
the bridge oh I can't see anything
mmm let mean I understand that piece of
it but then it's like if you're loading
what's there how is this thing set up
it's like how am i bouncing between
these little ping-pong ball between
these walls and trying to actually come
back yeah that's above my paygrade sir I
have no idea
shut up you also notice that if you have
a mite equipped you can see the compass
changes Oh like your radar up or
something like that
mmm interesting ours yeah I wonder how
many people have punchy actually built
what's going off with the I'm done as
much you can
they just said it's they all they're
saying is it's a marathon not a sprint
that's literally all they've said so
shoutouts a good Dakota Rose who's also
in my chat yesterday sorry little screen
just got a lot brighter so good I gotta
find that I've too many web too many web
browsers open too many - so some of you
may or may not know depending on your
history with Bungie they made a game
called marathon they made three of a
marathon marathon - and marathon
infinite so there are three games now
the original this is what she brought up
to me and as I had no idea though
the original lake AI in the marathon
game was called Durand Durand Elle
and of course Bungie always picks them I
mean they've done you know Charlamagne
and all these crazy things which only
seems to be a link to this to the Durand
L is the legendary sword of Roland which
is it's the famous sword of King Arthur
of Camelot and like Charlemagne the
Roman Emperor and all this stuff and
we're talking about a sword and you've
got a little tomb with a sword on the
top and we're all gone all right
what does that mean whoa so without even
like the spoilery date of mine stuff
they said they're no fun okay what's in
Marathon and I was even looking up
videos love the game marathon they've
been doing sci-fi shooters forever have
you ever looked at that yeah I never I
honestly never had I never played into
anything I missed that one I've never
played a I've looked at every I followed
their history yes I got beat up student
Xbox stuff yeah so it's this little like
sci-fi shooter it looks just like doom
but they've got the little sighs it's
like the origins you get to see their
beginning of what kind of would they
start exist like that that was actually
come on oh yeah apparently the AI in
there that you work with the system it
has the name and it's related to a sword
I'm like of course it is something like
of course of course it's going this way
to Easter eggs are stuff this is this is
class classic typical Bungie but a link
things to their past there's a lot of
significance and stuff like that and
that's just how they do it is just
really cool even I'm saying the way they
think these things through there's
always little nuances what I call
nuances then either tied to things to
their history whether it be getting wise
design wise character wise or wise
there's always that mesh they always try
to get involved with it it's it's really
cool but when I want to get to if that's
parlor but I'm being patient that's
gotta be at the end I can't do it now
for the end grumble grumble this morning
by the way you guys are all awesome
thank you for the saluting salute 39
yeah the more exploding this morning
which is brain
but before we get to that yes we did
actually get a swab top let's get it
it's been a minute and honestly I didn't
expect too much out of this one
yeah that's like okay we knew about the
puzzle but they're not gonna give it
away and this is all they say about it
the [ __ ] there is a mysterious new quest
being offered by the wily warlock who's
always messing about what time itself
the community is already what I'm not
use this quoting Watchtower what's this
wily warlock stuff messing around
hey we knocks we don't slam to the god
Osiris here that's not what we do but it
literally says exiled warlock on his
title come on I don't like wily warlock
dead guess I'm always messing about
that's a negative connotation I don't
like it you mean the desires the fence
for so DF yes right thank you Osiris
defense forward us right me and bread on
you and brother Vance like I'm with
brother Vance that's all you have yes
yeah that's right exactly
continue already on the case and working
together to explore the quarters of time
we don't want to spoil anything but we
do want to let everyone know this one's
a marathon not a sprint
and they said that on Twitter too so
it's kind of specific we'll keep an eye
on things so far and we're very
impressed with your progress
that's it that is all that's it very
late I said really yeah I'm like okay
no that's all we know from them iron
banner is coming next week mm-hmm
let's get it Pinnacle's I mean that's
literally all it's for but do pinochle's
even met this is what I wanted to bring
us like do you do you care about iron
banner right now um only yes only
because I don't care about the pinnacles
the more you're right but um I'm
actually behind on my season pass and I
gotta get that level that gives you the
extra perk on the sundial runs out 92 I
gotta get going on I'm like very behind
so my thing is I'm gonna snatch up all
of them Saladin's Val at Bernie's and
I'm gonna grab a whole bunch of Shaq's
bounties and just get cracking and then
once those go back go finish go back to
Shaq's real now and then that'll usually
get my experience going because again
even though we like the season and we
like narrative leeway I mean I like to
season Larry's where it's going
I can't say as a result I've been
playing all these monstrous hours
because I've gotten everything I've need
to get so as a result my season pass
experience thing is kind of low and even
with the dawning I played I got money
you know I got the sparrow thing I did
that but I guess I everything I did was
the most efficient way to get something
and I don't think I necessarily was just
all my everyday grind like how I always
so but in front of somebody I bake like
50 of the same thing bro that's
literally I yo set yo so repeat was mad
with repeatable balances were worth or
where it was that man I'm not sure took
advantage more of it the problem was I
was running out of essences yeah so I
had all the material I had so many more
materials than ever had a sense cuz I
yeah so I didn't play this I was like yo
yeah Chuvalo
I got these gala doodles what's up you
go take Olie was like I didn't have that
much essence so I just kept like pickin
before and are on the system pick up the
fiber and get out on the system at least
get the experience for him cuz you've
you turned the package and you don't get
anything besides the occasional return
in one other than that yeah so I did
those I met a hundred but I hit that
done
but yeah I was like the they're
repeatable bounties were crucial for all
of that yeah it's also just social level
in 100 I know
damn you already got there yeah yeah I'm
like 70 almost 80 I'm not yeah I gotta
be a little higher though to get this 85
or 90 Tuesday right you're looking for -
the burka was so bad is what preferable
perks at the end yeah I was there's some
sick rolls that I want especially for
more martyrs retribution for Patriot I
got kind of the guy role already that I
want nice um I think what is diffusion
gallon and their linear field yeah
gallant charge and and I wasn't lying in
the sand cuz I need rapid hit and um
firing lot but I want to get both you
know that robot diabetes I'm pretty sure
everybody on the towers needed an
insulin shot after that past month yeah
absolutely but yeah that's pretty much
it so I gotta get cracking on that so
that's why for me and then it's PvP come
on you know me and PvP is always gonna
have a slow spot so just something to do
in PvP I lost like control you know is
it any incentive for somebody like you
who's your battle pass is done and
you're done done no but for a guy like
me that's a little bit behind on that
yeah I'll be in there rocking and
rolling
so no no no weapons I see no new no no
no me like new season we might see about
a bow maybe yeah
got this like no your one arm or rolling
out no no new ornaments yeah going on
yeah complete the rocket launcher part
quests I guess Big O that's the it I was
ridiculous that was probably the worst
that's one of those were like they're so
data-driven and so all of this and
somebody is like and
sometimes you wonder how certain things
are like so minutiae down to like damage
was increased by twenty nine point two
six seven thirty nine percent and then a
request were you like hey everyone has
to pick up a rocket launcher ammo wrong
and it was so disgusted and heavy was
gonna be a pain in the butt and you need
ten wheels with it grow it was two
football teams over there but a heavy
all I saw so many Twitter like clips
gone back and forth somebody just like
Nova bombs the heavy kills six people I
saw that one of them might have been
YouTube that was right so like to say on
top of it double bubble's savage -
someone of each team that is pure
savagery team on the damn thing got a
bubble inside of a bubble both are
sitting over everybody's got shields
nobody can do anything ridiculous like
ridiculous mmm that's a bad idea
you gotta either put too heavy build
blocks in there or something I don't
know but yeah that was that was not the
best design finding over heavy the MVP
is never a good idea
it's never good so shout out to them for
making that an autocomplete step now cuz
we ain't gotta do that
thank God
well shout out to the world down under
by the way
yeah oh yeah idioms to the rescue I
don't know I saw Twitter just saying
everybody got one mine's already on
order I got mine last week we pledge to
support Australia's firefighting efforts
and the animal rescue and conservation
efforts due to the ongoing brush fires
devastating parts of the country I was
literally in twitching someone who's
saying they were actually getting some
rain and I was like I'm so happy for
those yeah huge today we shared the full
details and how you can support these
efforts by purchasing a limit Edition
guardians for Australia t-shirt that
also comes with a free starlight
Starbright
emblem as a thank you for your donation
this shirt is available for pre-order
here's a quick preview actually it looks
pretty cool too looks really cool yeah
like it it's got like the old gog ship
kangaroo down upon the ground with like
you and i'll be open like open australia
wilderness type thing you have a
traveler up in the sky i know it's just
really well done again mm-hmm so yeah if
you are looking at like donating
supporting anything out there find some
way to help support australia right now
those fires are three times bigger than
both the california and air amazon fires
like combined and they're probably even
worse i don't know the status of them at
least right now but i mean the amount of
effort the amount of animals that have
been lost there's there's so much that
needs to be fixed with that so please
please if you have any any funds to
donate right now
send them to Australia any which way you
can for sure nice thing about this
wonderfull shirt yes good cause y'all
definitely support man it's really
really bad what's going on over there
we did also get a baby hotfix it was a
couple days late it wasn't gonna be
Tuesday and now everybody hey try cuz
you know
guess what's gone
oh yeah we got yes yes gender has been
nerfed yes rest in peace to the homie
rest in peace it's a good run it's a
good ride you know we're back to the
votes you go that's sad man
it is yeah we talked about wish Enderman
I mean especially especially for you I
mean actually a dungeon that's your
that's your baby in a sense after a
while I saw some people going through
like soloing pit of heresy with that
weapon cuz it was doing so much damage I
just love to see the usage rate on stuff
that doesn't get used you know saying I
love it so I'm just gonna hope they can
reconsider the park yes we understand it
wasn't a technical nerf because it
wasn't intended to work that way right
yes but it should show them that that
weapon needs some form of a buff and
hopefully that comes man yeah but uh
some other things got some laughs your
break Nick let's go let's go so I'm
talking about let's get it has a higher
DPS at rampage x 1 and x 2 from twenty
one seventy twenty one twenty two twenty
one ninety twenty-four ten and then he
also screen shake on hard light firing
has been adjusted so no more shaky hard
light but break net man oh man that gun
got hit hard oh yeah it got hit hard
because they they killed all the
stacking perks then they killed rampage
to coming into the ground where they
kind of made it the only default thing
would rampage that still kind of
maintained its dominance was um was to
the submachine gun the one Lord Oh rodeo
almost tame it now Rekluse the the
exotic sub I'm making on it
huckleberry oh cool but how cool berry
benefited from everything now and I get
it but um pro you got it you're not
grinding a payment for tail you better
get breakneck are you kidding me right
back is fire what it is it's ridiculous
shoot to kratsov cheese get 12 times
that listen man this thing is really
strong you could eat on a rampage speck
on that bad boy not only are you doing
the DPS at two times and three times
even more you're getting those orbs
man's super regeneration and then with
the actual arm you know the way the the
seasoned artifact works you know you get
to certain ones you can take off the
rampage pack you throw on your little
overload I think it's this season's over
load so you can't use barrier but at
least it has some dual functionality you
know I'm saying but um nah man it's good
but it's it's what am i go to legendary
it's a slow starter but once you get
that rampage up you're decimating on
time streets
it's insane DPS oh yeah eight four two
point seven point one for that though
that's not life how long I don't know
one is on schedule so they said two 17.0
point two was wish endure getting fixed
the fusion rifle mod the Telesto braking
thing easy ah bliss
hmm couple basic things there some
bounties were fixed but yeah two point
seven point one is what's gonna have
breakneck fix hard light shake a little
like tamed in some director nice is
getting fixed a little bit and then
armor
yeah nothing made sir we have great next
a big one come with two point seven
point one okay so I was on schedule
here's a swampy so no date for it though
yeah and then hold on so two point seven
0.20 - yeah that is
that's live as of yesterday that's life
I said okay hasn't yesterday okay cool
said I'd add to basically test stops
blinking obelisk work yeah and you know
what you okay got it yep mmhmm yeah that
was done like the disabled weekly bounty
from banshee they see that's one of
those things where hey you can do a
weekly bounty every day but they'll
disable a weekly bounty that you could
do every day mmm as opposed to leave it
in there and be like oh you can get some
more cores and stuff why not leave that
in there what I saw that was even that's
one of those pieces they're so quick and
some people have said this and they're
not wrong they are so quick to shut
stuff down that is fun but if it is like
oh this is underpowered right now you
get to live with that for like six years
[Laughter]
daddy knows best you know how much I can
I never know which ones server side or
client side and stuff like that but it's
very convenient like hey we're gonna
disable this bounty yep quickly is gonna
allow you to earn a few more cores and
stuff every day
mm-hmm oh no if you did a weekly bounty
every day that's awesome not not saying
it's like hard to do but it takes some
time right and if you did that every day
it's like it's not the easiest thing so
you know you got to commit to it you
know and I mean I get it I guess but
it's just like you know again you know
you just weep like we've always said at
nauseam we want those paths we want
other paths to you know getting these
materials and there would be a cool way
you know I'm saying if more things like
that were offered but you know
mm-hmm but yeah that's mostly it you get
a couple movie montages which I'll have
to watch later but this had a slight
swab there's crazy weather apparently up
in Seattle so some of them are working
from home of course to manage the crazy
snow inches and inches that are up there
but the current activity is hush-hush so
we're gonna step back and watch as you
work together to solve it and they even
say like work together to solve it I
still I'm wondering I still AM I'm very
curious if the big giant crazy combined
3,000 line spreadsheet isn't really the
right thing to do or there's gonna be
somebody who pops up with the like hey
guys I got it mmm do you think as you
think gabon hi
I could see late it took six people to
run the raid before for outbreak and
then I know there's people who like hey
we had to recruit people who knew Byner
and stuff so he had pulled people with
different knowledge mm-hmm but it didn't
take like the entire community
submitting picture yeah you like the
streamers who are building a map like
you literally need thousands of people
doing it at that point and it's like if
you specifically can't do it with a
small group of people right even if it
is like hey you're small of group of
people can build your own map over time
or something like or you can do you
again have to be in there for like 19
different hours right like you might
have to do your own 19 different maps to
build your I I just don't know it seems
so weird hmm so what what's your overall
thing on this like wait where are you at
are you this is a good thing
I like where this is going are you this
better pay off in there something like
where are you I'm still confused on
where you are
Oh far - all right - damn it you better
have me doing this for some okay here we
go
so for me in his I want this if it truly
is Lake Grandia and I haven't seen the
spoiler so I don't know writer the spin
foil it's been for
Bua Bua tasties right now is on fire
what if the solutions to all this leads
to a 5% discount code or anthem if you
if it's 99 cents write down you take
five percent off that makes it ninety
five cents right no for me so like part
of me is like I'm not saying I could
figure out like the whole binary thing
that would take me a long time to do to
get the code you have to have like six
people to go in there and figure some of
that stuff out well the other side Oh
for me
I can't get like hey here's a group of
like four or five people or even say dad
oh he can't get his math class fire team
they can't figure it out on their own
Brett it's taking I mean if it truly
does take the 3,000 person image map to
put together mm-hmm that seems a bit
excessive even for bungie that doesn't
seem like this is too difficult easy to
difficult I'm saying it could be a
complete pain in the butt so a group of
six people like okay we're gonna work
together we'll trade off well like you
know however like one person's account
you got to do it for 19 like but if you
can't do it with a smaller group it
seems like even over a course of time
fate a so II say day so could be a week
long for all I care but if it takes
thousands of people that is just kind of
a weird thing to me Wow so so you would
prefer it not be this huge grandiose of
it is that what we do it it could be
long but I think the
complain complain complain this is a
whiny hardcore base what will make them
happy let's see now you're just waiting
true none cuz I know I knew where this
was I Bungie is trolling this is the
ultimate troll this is for you guys that
complain is over hey no this is why I'm
like okay so it's like it's a marathon
not a sprint
pace yourself mm-hmm they're obviously
like I was like I'm trying to think of
like the programming build of this thing
I'm trying to think of like okay so the
engineers putting this thing together or
you're telling me they're giving up like
you okay so every player out there we're
gonna have to make sure like thousands
of people do this thing so it's solvable
what if that didn't happen
what if it is gonna be in like a rate
race and like these small groups of like
six people weren't talking would it not
be possible
yeah you know what that was right now
you'll be less exact like they're
messing around they're better all right
so here's the game before they say I
feel them not everyone can participate
in this event B was tasty fast along
further together I like this energy I
feel like this is migas like if this is
a gamble by Bungie because they knew the
community would do it they know I know
that's like I know the computer D would
come together you got like thousands of
people to watch GLAAD and dado and stuff
like that but it still seems like it
seems to the point of would you stop I
don't want to know where you're going
I'm scared I wanna go with you go with
no I just like you it can be an
excessive it can be a crazy puzzle but I
think requiring that like literally
thousands of lines because some people
are submitting duplicates and they're
literally taking those things out of
there doesn't mean like the way they
wanted it solved that this is just what
I'm talking about with my chat last
night okay okay they're overthinking I
think the community is like you think
the community is over yeah Bunji puzzle
holy cool I want to know where you're at
with bungee on this when I know how it
solved then I can tell you how no this
is why I was trying like okay so I know
thousands of people are submitting
images that's crazy
there are some connections out there
cool but on the other side like what if
it is like some quiet team of like three
or six people that are capable of
solving it but they're going about it a
different way maybe it is every hour
they they get a new code and they ain't
like you can build your own puzzle
something like that and everybody's kind
of seeing theirs
it just seems like the thousands is
almost like the communities like taking
it to a level it never meant to be
okay okay you know issues with the
community your issue is that you did the
community's over thinking I I get that I
think and I could be completely wrong
because I mean they're finding like
starting points they're finding ending
points on these maps they're getting all
these things and there seems to be some
crazy big connections on the maps that
they've got so I'm like I'd be
completely wrong if I'm wrong this is
like one of the most amazing community
puzzles I've ever seen a cute that's
what's about to save yeah it's like why
about I support like if it comes
together that is a huge gamble by Bungie
the creators and stuff like that but it
pays off because they know their
computers absolutely their community is
absolutely insane right but in turn I
feel like I don't know if there's an end
game to their current methodology cuz it
just seems to keep growing mmm that's I
guess intersting interesting this is
interesting so I don't mind if a guys
puzzle dude you give me a puzzle it
takes a month don't care mm-hmm that
would be fine
but if it's if the community like
jumping on this thing
hey submit these images everybody's are
wrong I mean mathematically stuffs
eventually gonna start connecting if you
have enough people picked picturing what
if those aren't meant to actually
connect
whatever mine and yours aren't part of
the same build hmm like is there a point
where I actually start seeing like or I
can build maybe a bigger map for me
because I can go in right now and do a
nineteen piece puzzle
yeah all on my own right so I can do
that completely on my own that's right
so what's to say the bigger version
potentially whatever is gonna be
exploring all the corridors of time is
something that also can be done by
myself or a smaller group and doesn't
require 3,000 images from the community
right cuz I mean the way the little like
symbols are set up if you have enough
people out there seeing images your
balance just mathematically to see
something that actually match right so
they're just gonna keep throwing stuff
at the wall and be like all two of them
stuck cool right and there's a lot of
new hm
but it's just yeah it's really crazy
well you know that very well but maybe
it could be that it could be that I
think I mean to me it doesn't matter how
it solves it ba-barry like he's just
it's a unique concept you know if it I
will say this if it requires ultimately
the community as a collective now I
think that's one of the dope dope is
possible that one's like if it does
that's amazing like because yeah they
knew certain people are gonna come
together be like alright we got like
Photoshop or is over here we got
streamers to bring people together
we got raid secrets we got a reddit we
got to read it with you let me throwing
stuff in that disk you scroll through
the raid secrets reddit it's just like
images after images after instantly I'm
like love it love it yeah I mean it's
gonna be interesting to see like I said
once it's solved you know how how it
solved and then obviously the payoff
right there the payoff to this has to be
pretty impressive yeah right and um you
know we'll get to sweat stuff I don't
let it but you don't that that's gonna
be that's gonna ultimately rank this
thing and determine okay where is this
thing in the scheme of it me personally
I think it's cool you know what I've
liked a little bit more action in it yes
but I think it's dope I figure it's a
it's a cool concept to keep the hardcore
engage you know the hardcore has been
they've been longing for something this
season and I mean is this the best thing
you could do for them probably not but
at least it's something and I just like
the community I just like when the
community and you seen the streamers get
together and do all this stuff and you
know just really really combined notes
and you know
is is dope to me is dope so I'm gonna be
all for this regardless to its
difficulty being over my hip I'm all for
it this is this is what I like to see
destiny is more fun when everyone's
pushing together on whatever common goal
yeah I mean it's impressive to watch I
mean you literally have certain guys who
like there's a shared Google sheets dog
the like the main top people they have
access to other people are coming into
mm-hm are submitting images to those
leaders or actually and this is where I
think they may be overthinking it hmm is
because
they a lot of the main like people to
join you're like hey if you're on PC I'm
standing in the final room yeah join my
party activate it for you so I can take
a picture of your image that's where I'm
wondering if they're they're getting
information that they shouldn't be
looking at if they're getting more
information than they should be
because if like to be like hey we have
an open party for hours people are just
joining flashing their images taking it
reading it - and it's just this mahn
going party if somebody actually put all
these like puppetry master puzzles
together to be like yeah best way that
for them probably to do it is like leave
an open party it's gonna cuz they know
cuz if I go in by myself I see the same
thing over and over but if somebody else
goes in it goes in so if somebody else
continues so like they were revolving
party door and that's why I'm like I'm
wondering if they've gone a little off
the deep end of the Defago day your
issue is different your issue is the
community you have really you've already
asked my question your issue is that
dudes might be we call it what I used to
affectionately call it the third I might
be open for no reason that's what you
say like the third dudes run around with
the third eye and you say this thing
could not be that deep like I feel you
owe yourself go doughy oh not just we're
good noise a certain okay just let me
know if you got a roll out I'll hold it
down with a check if you think I'm crazy
do you think they're I mean with what
you've seen you know what do you think
oh god I got it listen y'all co-mentor
they - Volk is a possibility I mean I
will say this though it do feel like
everybody taking these images feel like
it is leading to something you know I'm
saying and um you know bungee hitting us
with the marathon not not us you know so
more like the brown wdu file for that
yeah but here's the thing it's like I
think it is lead to something that's my
guess I hope I'm right I hope I'm right
cuz how cool would it be that all this
like CSI you know the scientific
cool stuff and everybody's putting a
patch work together like that's dope to
me like I like it yes it is it's cool
hey I would like this ultimately to be
that deep where everybody had to be on
boss yo what's page 344 section five
give me the horizontal axis what's your
picture that's fine
get it together dude do it up do it up
y'all that's what I want and that may be
really really cool it's like and that's
why it's like when you bring up some of
the images that we've got of this thing
hmm some of them are just nuts let's get
crazy let's get crazy little Cyrus what
I was like if you look at so I mean
you've got some openings and thing I'm
trying to look at back my notifications
to know when mm-hmm there we go here's
the most recent one so if you're looking
at the images of what we've got you've
got some long
you've got some pieces that are all
chained together but there doesn't look
like a long path to go between them to
go between so you might have stuff that
starts getting stuck together but if
it's only three sections every time and
there's no actual route between
everything and there's no way these
things actually end up fitting together
great that's why cuz one of these is now
I mean you've got rough math of like
connected pieces because this first one
is now huge in the top left corner I
mean there might be a hundred pieces up
there but they're don't look to be a
whole lot of they're connected like yeah
past they're all like kind of like like
twos block together it's like three
sections and they don't look to be a
there's a chain now somebody else had an
idea that might be like spelling words
or something but that doesn't I mean
right now in the like a biology
experiment a whole bunch of little mini
microorganisms that's what I like to be
oh yeah organic chemistry straight up
right here yeah it's straight chemistry
you know so let's see you know sure the
head eh I'm worried about it
underwhelming rewarded this yeah they
got it they got it nail it
I whipped the ADHD got to nail him not
be like bro they can't us window you
know so that is awful everybody did that
he's like oh I'm just cipher the code
puts that over the top yeah no I guess
that's it I did the graphics of the
areas are good you always read yeah yeah
I will say the quarters of time is like
I mean it's in the background of our
podcast right now but that whole place
so space it's amazing yeah house is what
we do Osiris is no jokes aside like we
got to see we got to see man and see
what's going to shout out the deal yeah
go outside yeah that's how DVDs man
third eye sold for brother third eyes
over but uh yeah I'm dying to see what's
great it cannot be another niobe labs
where you just get like a ghost or just
an emblem yes I just lady rule of war
copy of like another love another Forge
like ya know that game no lore book no
no like you got to give us
something that leads to something or
something super-powerful or a cinema
something got to happen you're there so
before we get into
[Music]
questionable territory do you have
anything else you want to discuss
because I'm gonna put a big giant
spoiler warning out there for people who
don't want to know like I said I'm on my
break neck I'm good shout out to lfg I
want to shout them out you know that's
the PCL of G and legendary sundown which
was a little legend sundial yeah and you
need match do you think you did
matchmaking woodwork in there easily
like the purpose have taken it off like
it was just like y'all just be extra for
no reason now yeah it was it was a
little more you know a little rock more
rough-and-tumble in there with a couple
enemies you know saying but other than
that it was just like all right light
levels on there but if you're like all
that would literally is hey before you
go in if you're like match-made be like
no extinguishes on here if everyone dies
he will be kicked to orbit you can try
it again with another team this will be
more just something but like this would
have been the best experiment for
matchmaking just to see made us feel
like okay now I know why it's not in the
raid or hey I know what raid would still
be I wasn't talking but sundial a
menagerie did not need matchmaking to go
off no if none of those activities
required there are no level of raid
where it's like oh my god we have to be
in full communication on the left on the
right no it's none of that it's
literally shoot kill follow the
instructions you've been doing there's
nothing else deep about it so yeah they
kind of got a chill with that you know
and I hate the fact when we talked about
it we hate I hate the fact that you know
a lot of these pinnacles outside I am
bad at is no matchmaking that is
annoying can I get some matchmaking I
like it come on it the Destin community
is at that point you don't really need
to have it with the three men on the
other six magnitude of raids I get it
raves a different beast but we have
graduated as Guardians that we can have
hard pinnacle activities with
matchmaking odd I'm with that
shot the prize Prescott is patty's if
the hexes take us to Finch good debt
ever first discount baby go you have
these couple things that we've had
easily easily
I mean vex offensive if there was a
harder difficulty yeah match make the
same like though if that is
if that is the seasonal model
of a six-person match made activity for
new season there's a big question of
what's next season
Brian oneis wonder huge I'm very curious
but if it does seem to be
six-person activity match made harder as
not match made no reason especially as
we're gonna start to get higher and
higher level gonna be easier no reason
not to right
agreed don't but yeah that's all I got
as far as the season is concerned stuff
like that but alright we ready we're
gonna do a quick wrap already baby wrap
up here so then spoilers at the end mmm
you guys can find me we're doing
spoilers after this no I'm serious
spoilers is after this though if you
don't want no spoilers you don't want to
know rumors until this thing is solved
until you're in the middle of it
yourself you guys can go ahead and you
guys can find me Avant is twitch Twitter
at YouTube let me guys right here
subscribe to the channel you guess the
support has been amazing I'm following
Twitter as well to see what's going on
if I'm live that's everything for me
savant is everywhere yours
brief as well tell me again salut I'll
fill you yeah you already know me at
Lourdes Cognito and all that good stuff
we're not leaving job just we're not
little spoiled look we're not leaving
who's that people don't want to know
anything that's be Ottilie no Sam but I
get I have Norah Cognito you never
saying and I'm Lorde podcast Lloyd's a
gaming dotnet well don't you find all
the greatest finest articles you could
check that out and yeah man I'll tell
you about after this well is who might
be on a [ __ ] boiler for the
spoiler spoiler for the spoiler how
about that have our debt sad depressed
so down I read it you can talk about it
if you like cuz I gotta I gotta get
myself privy to this thing so it's like
alright so her name's boiler territory
so so much gonna have to read it now I'm
gonna do you want me to read just what
like Tassie wrote oh okay okay cuz I was
cuz that where you come from no I got
mines are way earlier and um you could
talk about talent as I had shoutouts
Paul Tessie might be back in a lot cast
soon by the way so looking forward to
how should I know he's saying spoiler
spoiler so spoilers everybody spoilers
flailing arms do not listen to this if
you have any interest of avoiding
spoilers
so a large amount of data mind voice
lines were found during the early season
of dawn they include lines from Saints
missions conversation between sax sax
sax sax and Osiris for the devil's or
inquest but they also contain something
else a eulogy a eulogy for us mmm
ears st. thank you for coming we've
gathered here today to celebrate the
life of my mentor my inspiration
they called him crota send a hive Bane
King Slayer the young wolf hero of the
red war
the man who avenged cayde-6 he had a
hundred titles I cannot recall and he
died doing what he does best defending
the last city of humanity ages ago he
saved my life and then inspired me to
save myself I'm glad he did because
traveler helped us he is gone and there
is no one to save us now on the day we
met I decided I would follow his example
I'm still trying
so yes that's confirmed to be our grave
before we freaked out too much about
this idea I will say that since were
loose in the quarters of time here this
is potentially just one of the endless
amount of futures and I don't think this
necessarily means we're heading towards
some grand destiny to finals that ends
in our death I mean it's possible yes
this is - TAS he's talking right now I
know this is Sasi this is full just a
C's article mmm but the fact that we're
visiting our own grave and hearing this
implies we could actually be erasing
this timeline as we speak but there's
more specifically relating to the
potential reward of the quest I've
marked this grave with one of his
favorite weapons shatter than the final
confrontation it used to be mine all who
find what we've left here please leave
it be unless unless you're still out
there somewhere
you performed miracles before in which
case take it and come back to us and
we'll kill what killed you or die trying
so it seems pretty clear that the reward
for this quest is going to be a weapon
mm-hm it seems extremely likely the
weapon is going to be a sword so what
he's saying I heard some people guess
that maybe shattered pieces of
Gjallarhorn are with us in the tomb but
saint says he's marked the grave with
one of our favorite weapons and sitting
on top of it is a sword and our
generalist go show you don't mark
something you don't mark something with
items with item inside the grave so for
it
that seems to be what he's got there's
more of as to what it could be because
there's different exotic swords and
stuff so right Frank what do you got oh
this is yeah I was definitely came
across this because I was like okay I'm
not doing that big puzzle y'all doing I
saw the date of mine thing I could not
resist I needed to know I needed to read
and it was voice it was voice that was
data bind and it's Saints voice you know
so um to read that it's extremely
powerful I mean to me this is now if you
want talk about third eye open stuff
that's actually cool and don't like this
to me
I won't this is the question I'm saying
that shot the fort say he's in here and
I'll put this out Twitter um to me one
of the biggest questions about d3 in my
opinion was how do you start
d3 right yeah because my thing is d1 to
d2 okay the lesions here they blew up
the tower or whatever you can't you guys
lost all your stuff right it makes its
progression wise while we don't have
anything anymore
right now d3 this could be dope like we
died and thus a new Guardian takes up
the mantle or whatever right we've heard
rumors of the darkness you know some may
choose the darkness I may choose the
light I'm gonna assume the darkness for
whatever had to kill us had to be insane
insanely powerful which would set up
space Doritos space Doritos on a thread
that's the endgame that's the ultimate
thing so they would be capable of
killing us right so they could either
set it up as this ultimate sacrifice you
know now the new Guardian we now you
know take on the mint and we go Evangel
we go whatever so I think story beat
wise
it makes sense I'm curious brittle it's
ballsy for buns you don't even put this
in the game I'm curious if they will
execute come d3 I still don't think d3
is right right right now I think we're
still a little bit of a ways away maybe
20 September expansion always yeah I
think 2021 is d3 that's my guess for now
right
we I think this year we have another you
have the season and pass we'll have
another rasa fire and slash taken King
September of 2020 but I think this is
actually cool if this happens this way
that's a perfect segue to d3 lore why
story wise and I would like it man oh
and then also means st. is a permanent
fixture and we all love st. we've all
felt that they've heard something even
though it's the landing zone and the
hanger that's all I was wrong I've never
you know I'm a warlock me right now how
could you not like saying like say is
amazing like he makes you wanna play a
Titan like it's ultimate Titan
beastliness we're in pcs in the game
mmm-hmm let's compare them up just get
it Titans vs warlocks who do we got us
in pcs unfortunately I've got a giant
like dead weight on the end of my rope
you you talking from a position of
strength but he's smart messing with
time you got out I Cora who's at least a
strong figure we've got Jack's we've got
Saint and then we have dumbass in the
backs of all the average
he's still powerful got to go alright
now be just by man I Cora yeah I mean is
it what you call the wall up isn't I'm
crazy um a Shamir huh I forgot what's a
Shamir what is he I thought he was a I
think he's made from laughs yeah he's
wore lucky yeah um I don't know some
library and archive guy type thing yeah
for forte you already know who's coming
baby the god they've you know for the
hunt is my main ask about favor hunter -
it's gonna be LG I've got a video voice
of Ojibwe I am gonna rep Aldrin to annoy
all the hunters who lost my favorite
everybody who don't like cake it was a
man you know saying but um not all jokes
aside we already know what the hierarchy
is tightness is running the show like
it's just what it is this I've accepted
it that's just how it is
but my favorite is still say he's number
one he gotta give it to him what shacks
is my emotional context my - oh man dude
I was loving the banter more the devil's
room quest and he's like what's the
hooker it shoots bullets he's talking to
his old grandfather plays games grandpa
that's why mommy like you feel I love
sex bro he's like yeah we don't give
weapons how eighties are talking about
that's what I love yo loves warlocks I
forget I think both Cosmo probably both
play a hunter cuz they play a buttload
of PvP yeah hunters need some love hunt
is nice in love child to heart pairing
up imma hunting me I'm looking forward
to Aldrin I hope he doesn't come he does
become yacht B - I don't blame her for K
because he was being manipulated they're
gonna have the whole story I'm telling
you Tasi has a good article the perfect
redemption
is safe 14 training him yeah and the
ways of the Vanguard and showing the
forgive state is the perfect character
to bring him now Corrigan went to smoke
a cordless just be like hey glad to keep
her on her side of the tower she now the
funny thing is this is Cevallos payback
he's gonna had ultimate I told you so
[ __ ] I said cuz I was like yeah do all
your actions led to this now we gotta
embrace him that's where the viola is
gonna get the payback on cuz member she
went in on him she was like you were you
sure we shouldn't call him a coward she
could the man Howard Howard as' we're
not gonna fry [ __ ] I got like that was a
powerful thing I actually fell in love
with a cord that was like damn she went
in on him so yeah that's pretty much
what it is but um I I want Aldrin he's
the perfect redemption you read the law
piece what the what is it the amnesty
ship of God you pronounce it yeah and um
yeah he's right he's running around with
his helmet on depressed doesn't
understand why people hate him he just
wants to you know yeah yeah he still has
to make his trip back to the time that
he has to go back that's part of his
líneas his ghost as is uh as his path
and and as the hunters there he is their
vanguard so huh that's not one man shot
that shot to mommy I got a slow burn on
this my god get it slow yeah real taking
this wee time yeah it wasn't I'm trying
to think
forsaken Calista just forsaken was it
and if was se caen dr. cutscene yeah
when we did the the the Queens Court
thing yeah
now that was like a couple of weeks
after forsaking the raid was beaten we
were doing shattered throwing stuff we
did all that did the cinematics just
randomly pop up it was it came nah man
you did you a weekly ascendant thing
yeah will you go to that and you look in
and you go into her world and that's
when he you saw Benny said look into the
hourglass click to go back home
yeah my mom was like boom he's awakened
you're like and that's the thing I think
that's again goes back to dados
questions of like yeah what is going on
with all these stories can we get an
idea with one of these six dangling
threads that's out there can we get some
work on them I know they're like
building a world but man like Aldrin
said now I gotta stretch it that curves
for the Dreaming cities still being
their Sabbath old it's just lurking
still we still got her we got like we'll
get the mail with the pyramid ship for
like the start of shadow 23 yeah but and
then it's like
hello yeah it's like all these story
cred they did teasing it said things up
I just wonder it still that right I
don't I wonder if there honestly ever
gonna be able to end half of the stuff
set up half of his stuff they got a lot
they got a lot they've got a lot is it's
it's yeah it's gonna be a [ __ ] but I
think that's where the season pass the
annual pass format is gonna help them
they're gonna be able to do these yep
story bits during then these non content
periods and I'm cool with it that's why
I'm like I'm not really complaining I
thought I would be if you would have
told me last year us doing you know when
it was flashpoint if you would have told
me hey [ __ ] I'm gonna give you a destiny
season with no ray no dungeon no trials
one activity and you're gonna love it
you're gonna you're gonna have good I
don't like what you kidding will you get
out of here with that that is not what
I'm looking for if you'll just tell me
that on face value I'll be like no but
I'm sitting look at us we're sitting
here within rules we got hexagon
diagrams out we got graves out here we
got st. you know it's a lot of things
going on with the law was hitting this
what it proves to me is this game has
such rich lore that it excites you when
dots do connect yeah you're like oh okay
this could go and this again if they
execute this pretty ballsy unless we
gotta give him credit to for the aldryn
thing how ballsy was that we did a whole
DLC avenging Kay this got a guy that's
beloved right amazing Barrens guess what
you thought it was over chi minh city
wow this is amazing just great content
great content great content and then to
have it flip and to do this whole almost
a Redemption flip with this character
that we hate it
no that's good storytelling bro that's
great great story ton and I hope like I
said this is this is really something
with the lore team that I've been very
hard on them over Destiny's lifespan and
to see them kind of coming through with
these story bits lore community is happy
right now man this is good stuff yeah
mm-hmm it's been a hell of a journey man
yeah absolutely it's the same think of
like you had the crota and that kind of
journey going on with the hive and then
we've got Leviathan still sitting out
there with Calais we don't know if he's
a finger nice
he's another loose thread right we still
a meet this new we don't know what's
going all the cows like that it's again
you know it did they're sitting on gems
of lore tons of stuff and what they can
do now to your point though you made a
good point
I hope they have enough time to actually
get these threads done yeah I hope in
this game's lifecycle some things do
some of the stories yeah we definitely
do lose these some endings for some of
these stories
cuz I hope it's just not too much and
enough to never get solved and then you
know like blows out seasons yeah we're
out in like who knows where you got four
more dangling here at stories and then
bungees done and you're like yeah OCD
people losing their mind like I need
some Oh bro shall be would say we just
forgot about drifter he forgot about his
whole thing right with the nine and you
know why are we doing he's he and I
think he plays a remember we made that
decision yeah to pick him we gotta see
what I go that still never came back
yeah but he I'm flipping he saw the
pyramid ship and it was the pyramid ship
that one are they actually coming is he
gonna be involved he's still in the
tower he's still in a towel doing his
little making moat energy thing that
he's doing with his ship mmm-hmm yeah
gaming Forte's like we're gonna die
because Calais will be betrayus house is
gonna swallow the whole solar system
with it [ __ ] haha I'm just gonna go
through and vacuum up all the planet
yeah there you go little lunesta there's
a lot old much just lingering at this
point and now it's like
again is this gonna be a setup for
another thing or are we gonna get any
type of Lake finished even what we're
doing right now with the puzzles
and it's like are usually gonna be just
like a possible future I mean where the
quarter is sometimes so maybe you can
yeah that's true uh sure - I was like
you could see just a possible future
yeah I mean at a she could be completely
right - I don't want to ignore him I
just think it's dope if he's wrong for
it like it could be literally just a
future that we seen and we could prevent
the I mean that's what Osiris does
literally that's where he's going now we
know what he does he's just in here
looking at timelines looking at
possibilities and then it's okay this
can't happen so we got to make sure we
cut this timeline out and this just
could be something like that that's just
really cool you know whatever but I am
curious if they're not gonna do this
right if they're not gonna kill our
guardian
then how do you start d3 since right how
do you explain cuz you know they gonna
hit us with the BS you don't have your
weapon your town no no we're exploded
again and your vault is gone you're like
I'm not doing that twice and they cannot
pull the towel exploded again to hit
come to pyramid ships and we've lost the
tower again no we've been there we've
done it they're better than this that's
one part of me says de Scott to be it
but if you like me setting it in the
game now I don't think I could see us
dying that I'm not a police but let's be
real no but let's be real but why would
I why would it be like we're supposed to
find this yes we are not this I mean
number the date of mine stuff we were
supposed to find the date of mine and
annoyed if you see there is gonna be in
2021 there's no reason this needs to be
in the game now you guys sounds like
series looks like I feel like it's way
too soon for that to be any linkage to
d3
so yeah I feel it yeah he feels that
this is not connected this is just like
a random day I think it's just gonna be
like it could be like one of those
timeline possible future thing possible
future maybe there is a source so my
question to you guys I snow says day I
mean I start let's let's let's theorize
this let's put up to minute like what
you're saying like some how do you start
d3 know what do you guys how can you say
we're the same Guardian right you know
we're going to lose all our stuff no but
if we lose we went to stay 14 now and is
here
yeah
so for me
we can't have the stuff blow up again
it needs to be
it needs to be something major I don't
know if we are like stripped of our
power and maybe we go dark side or if we
like something like that would be cool
or if we just make new guardians I mean
they want you to be on this journey
there's rumor number two that we forgot
remember all murmur - with d3 the or
something was leaked or some supposed
source anonymous whatever his name was
remember they said they were supposed to
be a choice between Guardian t3 which
start off with Guardians choosing the
light or the dark yeah
again that was something that was leaked
in from a supposed anonymously who has
been right for a while I don't know I
don't know Sasha at the harpy Ariane
he's got some good stuff yeah it's like
the darkness kicks her but it probably
kills us and we were either reborn as
dark or light so can you imagine that's
what I'm saying
that's what what if they pull like a
fortnight one in the end of destiny to
is seasons wrapping up we're like the
veils starting to come like the fights
are getting more intense and then
finally it's just like if you're logged
in on the last day of destiny to just
like everything just nobody dies but
nobody's getting rest just go sitting
there and you can't in like the respawn
button it's not there it's like you have
been here ever lost or something like
that it just says I'm like ego and you
just get like and they just start
shutting down destiny to cope with that
be chillin chillin that's the way to do
it rolling back I love this idea I hope
they got the balls to do this yeah you
guys could be right I mean you know I'm
just about over the past three years I
would you'd accept it you'd accept that
you got the people who enjoy the lore
and stuff would happily accept the
people who are like I just want to play
this game and get all my guns and have
my fun and be like why did you take all
my guns cuz it's a new game enjoy no
game cuz we got to get rid of Telesto
yeah we gotta get all these broken guns
but you know like yeah man shot the
Forte I believe this is the future we
can avoid at some point we'll have to
face the evil that will kill us we just
fight everything into that yeah I mean
it could be something that we could try
to avoid it it could be like okay yeah
okay yeah that's what I think I think
this is an eventual eventualities yes
that we could try to delay its
inevitable run from it
well that was the wheels Lou it almost
seemed like I mean we were in the Vale
ship as powerful as whatever that being
type situation is how was he feeling
hey just what is like is that the point
where the darker the light is that where
you get to go choose the side of the
traveler the side of the darkness in
like well literally the d3 you log in do
you pick traveler or pier
remember finish if we fit it we finish
goddess out ask our salvation rate
salute the sky row this I'm not long and
might need to work on that Elizabeth at
the end of the day we ended that
salvation way the darkness gave us a
choice it was like you I'm not to do did
you think I am
all right you got it all twisted that
travel out here life you know maybe our
guardian was you know he was D with
disobeyed he wasn't with it he got
struck never literally hinting all these
things right in front of us man I think
it'll be cool it it still neo mentor he
said only haven't bring it back slowly
it's not they want to bring back some
things but let's be real they want to
introduce new things so how you you
can't really do that let's be real when
the loop [ __ ] out there lonely had a
fantastic point on this I maybe a couple
of podcasts ago when you have a looter
shooter right
we've got all these archetypes right all
these weapon types all the RPMs
eventually the loop becomes dance
there's only so much more you can make
in said category
you gotta start over you gotta type out
yeah
now he was mentioning like
decommissioning like I don't know old
stuff like number like the better Devils
line of d2 you know stuff back I don't
like guns going away you're saying what
it's happening you there is no way the
best thing we gonna get is a nice little
emblem at the start
hey you play d2 you know we may get a
montage like how we had before yo I was
with E and scare over we beat guarding
the salvation on this date and then
having that like we'll have a little
memorabilia you may get one or two items
but they are not bringing us back when
we login to d3 day one with all of our
stuff I can tell you that that's not
happen if it says nothing we are
starting over fresh and let's be real at
that point we'll be deep into that deep
will be in year one a full year of the
next-generation consoles you know I'm
saying they can leave I do not write
that crap for ps4 I am severely and by
then it'll be a full year from the
series X who will then leave the Xbox
one and the Xbox 1s and all that crap
behind they'll have the same Navi right
yeah yeah the Xbox right the Tower of
Power you know so like what can they fix
the naming ideas oh my god today was
stupid I I can't stand the name we
conveyed hi I'm an Xbox can I do not
like the naming conventions but that's
just me
but yeah like do card the creations
hopefully by then we'll have beards and
mustaches and all type of Quan Chi
Lawson who knows what else
yeah and if you want to bring your basic
face forward maybe you do that but your
man's dead so you can't do that I just
thought about it yeah that would be like
we need for them this is the type of
time if they're able to financially
afford it to you know do the revamps to
the system that they need get deeper
into
that RPG mechanics type stuff
dedicated servers cross your fingers
that could come in like two years cuz
like if you want PvP to be an actual
thing on next-gen consoles with cross
play cross play would be a bit too and
that would be the thing and that's why I
was like I think it takes the best part
they roll up PC need their own PvP lobby
no I've said this without the destiny on
to filter I was on a podcast or one of
those and choose the part in opt in yeah
you got give them with you cannot let
you cannot let console dues running me
they would get roughshod over Vivi
school will be spooky you know say and
DDoS and all that yeah absolutely you
know saying so give the opt-in have your
dedicated servers like ISA continue you
use all usual role yeah just all of
those things to be you know more RPG
mechanics maybe it's a light and dark
type thing we're actually fighting
different sides and different stories
and stuff of that nature is he's saying
avoid the DDoS and get us some dedicated
servers so that stuff like you don't I
mean am I crazy but it's like does
ddossing happen in Call of Duty
I don't play enough today I was like I
really don't know if ya let me know or
you listen to this in the comments I
haven't played call of duty in a while
but I don't know if that's actually a
thing because I feel like Call of Duty
is done it is not done on dedicated
servers right there's has to be so I
mean the okay just go smack somebody
through there's they Tracy a pretty like
they'd figure it out pretty quick though
again it's not going to stop everything
completely nobody's it's it's a more
controlled environment to better
matchmaking environment a better
situation for a lot of lag situation
that that's the big it's just a more
stable environment that it has a little
bit more control cuz peer-to-peer is not
it not right now here it appears new go
so yeah and a half the characters on the
other team are from the other side of
the world I'm like yeah yeah no I mean
there's been some really ridiculous
things I've seen on Twitter for like
little lips of like I'm gonna be an
electrocuted through like halfway across
the route like map and then just some of
the other things I've just like lag I'm
like it's those moments when you're just
like annoyed it's like my games do this
they're back and forth and back and
forth and like amaya closer to the
hosting side I have a pretty good game
did I feel like I can't hit the broad
side of a barn I must not be remotely
near the host and I can feel it and it's
a you can feel it and I'm not gonna say
GBP I'm okay but it's like when you
flip-flop like that and it could be the
skill in the match Lobby too but when
you can hit your shots and can't hit
your shots mmm it's yeah that the
server's I want like I want stats that
actually give a damn
doesn't matter this yep we do though
this everything they finally admitted
when they went solo they are in our MMO
they said it for the first time they
have a long opportunity if we know I
know you're not happy I get it
let's be real we're in the experimental
phase for the ultimate goal of d3 pure
MMO pure hardcore you know everything
that II need so you know saying did it's
harder when you're in game doing it
because you can only do incremental I
know kind of update because you can't
upset the applecart so much right but
when you give someone a clean slate like
kill your character it's not fresh the
dedicated servers across play you know
that's the opportunity to really buckle
down and put all the ideas you really
wanted to implement and let's put the
main thing to new engine tools faster
meta changing like a screen shot mode
can't tell you how many sources want to
pull my weapon off of my screen and just
take a screenshot Christmas tree show
when I'm ready gorgeous and so gorgeous
little moment I'm just like photo mode
that's all ball with me photo most so
many next-gen and again at that point
2021 and beyond consoles will have
caught up
we'll have those beasties ends and those
beastie navi's they'll be right ps5 will
be rockin they would and they'll have
those SSDs yeah whoo thank you for
putting me on a daddy Jesus it's night
and day boy I'm SSD bougie boy I can't
even touch my xbox well I bought it SSD
for max bucks yeah that's how bougie I'm
like you're not doing this I'm not
sitting here I can literally cook food
and go to go from orbit to the tower
like that that's ridiculous
but um yeah man look I'm excited I hope
I really hope they do this I really hope
they do it is a man I think this will be
a ballsy move but a cool move and then
it excites me I hope it happens I really
do
I'm with you nut as well just to be like
can you build your own can you like can
you build your character the way you
want to yeah I'll be nice for master
work - yeah so yeah there's a lot of
hope obviously there's a whole lot of
speculation on this one because it's
been a quiet week and there's a giant
mystery still going on so we don't know
what's happening my hunch if the
spoilers are true is then that is a
possible timeline but they're almost
setting us up to be able to know that we
can experience that sometime in the
future I don't think now sets up d3 but
I think our Guardian dying to get to D 3
makes sense I would actually love them
be like hey destiny two servers are
going offline
how angry would people be if they
brought back trials and then they shut
it down though mm-hmm like no trials but
it's in d3 or get trials now but it
shuts down and then you lose it again so
quickly if you kill everything in
destiny too and you want to actually
kill if you did a fortnight moment of a
black hole and you come back every year
but I'm just saying even enjoying it for
a year and it's ripped away
hey it happened to d1 we had to deal out
of that to is do you think they would
rid of like the Vanguard what everyone
died or were just we died in the light
with the Vanguard survive travellers I
think I I think we probably got like
means like well there's one mole on
board or shacks we got like one more
major death who's good we got a look you
got you know the secret who's gonna
survive look at the voice contracts who
who's Rd cadre who who's cost too much
let's read and cost a lot I don't know
but he's very loyal to the games I don't
know that's ready to seem like he's
loyal sound and you know yeah see you
know was the guys with the biggest names
Dane coming back like all those dudes
like that do to speak it was most of all
I see him literally tweeting that he's
playing best name so I feel like he'll
still there you know he he out he's
hardcore I also to see him go like if he
actually he would be one who would like
be
trying to think of the right word he
would be the one who would be like
redeemed by like a sacrificial moment
yes he would like know if he gave you
know his so if he gave him so he would
find this admit to himself in history
but that's the only way he could go well
I agree the base would would feel that
yeah he would it wouldn't be the perfect
way to go out
and let's be real they got the perfect
replacement already was sait so yeah you
know they will get over it we're gonna
only fail yeah you got different
tightness but I was like but I think
Zavala if he did sacrifice that would
actually be a a really cool story moment
for him mm-hmm
maybe he sacrificed himself for at Quora
I Korra's just as like don't do it not
this time I can't lose you and he's just
like go I've got this I've got this
forever and he has like half a
planet-sized bubble and you know the
power of it is gonna kill him or
something like that yeah
starts cracking and you see them going
down yeah they can have a real emotional
ball before bed doing right man all
right send them off right that would be
cool I don't with it mmm don't you think
trials coming back as a battle royale Oh
God Oh Lord no don't you say that
that evil word you know say that evil
word in here I think
I'm hoping battle Royales kind of had
their peak and yeah the ones that are
still in it between basically pubsey and
fortnight and apex are the ones that
have survived
that's basically it it's a game-mode
that's out there now those three can
keep their live service thing going it's
fine but ya know Charles would be fine
like I said we have it we'll rock out
you know I'm saying to the end of the
two and then yeah they're gonna shut it
down oh just like they did deal on it
will be a shutdown period and you know
d3 launch and let's see when they bring
it back or whatever but um and you know
how punch it kick it take a stuff way to
bring it back so buddy does yes mmm I
don't know yeah
obviously the second half of this
podcast has been a whole lot of
speculation but spoilers about or data
mining I should say but as of right now
this is recorded on the 17th so we don't
know what's happening with the puzzle as
of now so if you listen to this later we
don't know this would be a cool podcast
to go back to and a couple in like a
week so play depending on how long it
takes yeah yeah that'll be this will be
recorded because just to see where our
theories are how things land have you
don't oh yeah what is it what this
number 87 somebody I remembered number
87 as the one of our speculation for d3
dying that would be I would lose my mind
if I did log into d3 and it was
literally traveller or a pyramid and
you're like pic and like what what I was
like what does this mean if I pick
darkside can I never play with kognito
if he goes travelers in the truly horde
and alliance like World of Warcraft PvP
member yeah that was the big red that
remember that guy who was leaking was on
fire up into that point we haven't heard
from him since he was supposedly inside
collection on Bungie no one was going on
and he was finally fired there leak yeah
they got to snitch yeah it's gonna be
it's gonna be crazy I can't wait I can't
wait lot of attention I think we're
coming up towards about two hours on
there so you guys got mine before I move
on to see everywhere I'll let him just
give us the give us the the juicy
tidbits on who's your guest and we will
we will get these awesome folks out of
here you guys have been amazing you guys
went on stream has been off fire solo
for rock and when I signed act crazy
speculation you already know at logon
you again and on Twitter and of course
you want to gaming down that is the
website please check us out yes this
Sunday iron Lords
podcast special gas we have the PR and
community developer of compulsion games
miss Nyjah nyla Hodges amazing
compulsion has some great
great potential they've been actually
signed now is one of them Xbox game
studios and I think they were an initial
game they made first games like contrast
for ps4 but he was a ps4 launch title
and then are we happy few and now as a
small studio you know to get the backing
I have from Microsoft and you know to be
part of that little Pantheon I'm gonna
see what they got coming up next on
excited talk to she is a hardcore gamer
and cosplay she's really cool um yeah
man I can't wait to have her in the
round pick up brains talk gaming or talk
about the latest topics obviously PR
Sony with the whole III thing we'll talk
about her Russell seen her dawn going to
PC giving you out of speed to sneak peek
right now so we got a lot of so many
topics some Xbox Tom please check us out
son delays game delays Oh crazy stupid
again but yeah yeah appreciate it and of
course like I said Sony's 1 p.m. Eastern
and of course the last word with my man
d Banton sorry for some big s that God
won't put me up there something he's up
in yo to go yo we got to get him to the
summit or power when he in there get him
to the summit so he could do what he do
so he can influence this game i we want
so yeah no doubt of course ok the
statues up right now if you like big
statute shall remain King David he's got
it going on right now he's got Loki he's
got Greenland if you like comic statues
man please check this guy like he's
killing he's giving you lord give me
synapses about the character really cool
stuff man if you like that stuff so
check out
that's like that's all I got so thank
you guys so for today we wrapping up
right at 10 o'clock this is episode 87
of the last word and we've got a couple
weeks look forward special guests we're
looking to try and get a couple people
in here definitely one right around
Empyrean foundation so we know that's
gonna be so good
it's trying to get against post after
that wants to stay tuned that'll be a
good one
mm-hmm shout out to our 49ers trying to
hold it down this weekend man ready go
so hopefully this weekend and then one
more one more baby we take care of
business we go to the ball baby whoo
that's the girls do it with six that is
all we got so until next week hopefully
we're still smiling ear-to-ear episode
87 January 17th and it has been the last
word